i'm not saying that's what you're just
looking for reasons to beat the [ __ ] up
people we really were yeah and that's
horrible it's horrible way
i'm ashamed of that uh in my later years
but that was the case
uh back then so we would i say that i
preface it to let you know that when we
went to this
country place this country bar it was
all
uh you know if you got up to do karaoke
it was country music like
like the old school country music like a
family tradition you know me want to
know hang on i
do you drink to get drunk why
do you roll smoke oh how much you
live out the song that you roll
to get paid over and over
everybody made my prediction
if i get stoned and sing all night long
it's a family tradition
they want to hear this all right they
want to hear all this so then i get up
i got to tell the guy i'm like y'all got
nothing but a g thing he goes
really i say yeah nothing but a g thing
and i'm not talking about one two three
into the four
i'm talking about back peppa pigs
like that's what i'm talking about so
then that starts playing everybody's
like
look there's this white dude up here and
like that won't be about
like they're getting they're not they're
a little edgy yeah yeah we but we knew
that's what was that's what was our
intention right right because we were
idiots
so we really really were just idiots so
he's like let's see what kind of ruckus
we can cause
and then uh so he gets up there and then
uh
i go one two three and two the fault
snoop doggy dog and dr dre is at the
dope
ready to make an entrance so back on up
cause you know we're about to wrap this
up
giving a microphone first so i can bust
like a bubble compton in long beach
together now you know you in trouble
ain't none but a g thing baby two lo low
g's going crazy
death row is the label that pays me
unfatable so please don't try to fade me
so then i'm doing this and i'm saying
the whole thing next thing i know i'm
watching these people and ronnie and
randall are back there they're back
there in the back background
you know because it's like it's the
intent is to cause a ruckus yeah
and then you you start seeing these kids
you start seeing these cowboys go
you know and the next thing you know
they're up dancing
and they got they're all doing it right
they got their hats on great
and they're doing this and i was like
now this ain't going the way we are but
this is cool right here right well this
this is cool man they wanted me to come
back all the time
at this place and uh ended up making
friends where
it was like a real it was a moment where
the reason i was to be honest with you
um my dad when i was growing up
my brother you got you got siblings yeah
you got a brother i have a uh step
brother and a half sister
did you fight with your step brother
yeah like fist fight yeah
yeah actually not like a real fit not
like a real fist fight we got
we never got into like a legitimate
fight but we got into a lot of fights
where there was like wrestling yeah a
lot of scuffling a lot of scuffling well
me my brother we got in fist fights
like legit fist fights and my dad this
is where this stems from see my dad
instead of saying
did you ever get in fights with your
brothers it wasn't
no more scuffles yeah what did your dad
say to you what was there what was your
what was their advice to you
uh i mean when my i have a younger
brother so
when in times where we would get to
scuffling around he'd be like you know
you know go outside and we would wrestle
it out you know and then
as the big brother you're trying not to
hurt your little brother but you just
want to show them who's boss
let them know hey that ain't cool
marty's dad was like well he gave you
all gloves yeah
yeah he literally said yeah y'all okay
y'all gonna fight put on these boxers my
dad was like
yeah you want to fight do this so we you
know we're boxing
we're literally in there that's how we
think this is how you handle problems
like when me and my brother would get
the
arguing like get them gloves get the
[ __ ] glove
this turned into a thing where uh we
would box
kids from school in our front yard like
it would be like events
my brother was very good he was very
really like an actual he became
an actual very talented actual boxer he
could
he could have done it at one point
because he was actually very skilled i
was just wild like
yeah when he when we would box he was
always like you know
standing by he's taller than me you know
he's like six two yeah and he uh
he would always stand back and he'd try
to be scientific and i'm just like
i'm like a bull like that
you know and then eventually i just
tackle him and try to take him down
because i was bigger
yeah in size but not taller right so
then i could
because he would be popping me as i'm
coming in like
pop like that and i'm like i get it i'm
like getting mad you know
i'm getting mad so then i just tackle
him and i'm the man at this point yeah
and then i'm winning
because i can i'm heavy you know i'm a
heavy boy stay down
yeah you can't tell it i hide it well
yeah i'm a heavy guy yeah you can seal
it well
yeah i do thank you conceal it i like
that that's one of them
that's one of them one of the rich boy
words rich boy words
no so when you i think as a child
it might not affect everybody because it
was kind of the same with him and you
right but it to me because of the way my
dad reacted to that i was thinking
that's just how you handle problems
right you fight if you got a problem you
just you just fight it out
and it was years later i was like that
ain't how you handle problems man
that's dumb but anyway we made friends
that night at shooters instead of
enemies where we were we thought we was
going to make enemies it just comes
it really stemmed from boredom yeah you
know that type of thing just being
stupid kids
and being bored we had fake ids just
like you we weren't even supposed to be
in there
we were under age that at that time
really
yeah we had fake ids too to this day i
still messed up my
social security number because we had
fake
fake socials yeah yeah i might be a
little bit like john bozeyak
i'm more like him than a than i thought
but all i did was change the last number
so i would always remember my fake one
yeah to this day sometimes i mess up my
real one that's
hilarious and i asked i asked my wife i
say what is my is my social
is it a is it a two or a three at the
end what's the whole thing though
yeah what's your name hey i got a
lifelock at least she's got it at least
she has these she she knows she knows
she got so she knows it
so anyway um
roadhouse you never see roadhouse
roadhouse i don't think so
patrick swayze dalton he's a bouncer
it's i don't think i've seen that it's
the most masculine movie of all time is
it really yeah
never seen it i need to watch it i need
to watch roadhouse i do need to watch it
when did they come out
80s late 80s roadhouse did you see
roadhouse
next time you watch family guy you're
going to be
what is this explain what this is it's
just a family guy joke
yeah but what's the joke peter is
referencing roadhouse
the movie he's jacked and every time
they
you know ask him something it's his
answer roadhouse
he's just you seen that you seen it
jared right
it's a pretty funny little whole episode
thing they do and what do they give me
one real quick one question they ask him
that he responds to the roadhouse
i'm just gonna totally make this up like
peter will you go to the store and get
some
crabs uh quagmire's coming over later
and then peter's like roadhouse
[Music]
that's pretty great we'll just start
doing that that's pretty [ __ ] great
yeah when you see that
that's it really is one of my favorite
movies of all time i'm gonna watch it
this weekend
look for the part where he goes like
this right here you know what i mean
just just keep this in mind okay what's
he do like what's he doing no i'm not
telling you you just keep you just
remember i did this to you i did this
you almost died remember that okay this
is this is near death
you know what i'm talking about mm-hmm
don't you ever see a roadhouse
you remember this yeah yeah baby this is
crazy
this right here is crazy i've been
trying to do this ever since i watched
that movie
what the [ __ ] is it you're going to find
out hey this guy back here knows don't
see roadhouse austin
austin austin look at these computers
they got the most massive computers you
see the screens got like a thousand
screens i think austin is actually
playing some video games i think he's
streaming twitch back there
austin are you streaming twitch austin's
got a hot new girlfriend you brought
over last night where is she cast yeah
where's your girlfriend today